esta vez hablaremos un poco de
congruencia de segmentos de recta bien
llamar hemos enunciado 1 a este que
tenemos aquí esta es la definición de la
congruencia de segmentos de recta o al
menos es la que usaremos que dos
segmentos sean congruentes significa que
podemos mapear un segmento en otro
usando transformaciones rígidas ejemplos
de transformaciones rígidas son las
reflexiones rotaciones traslaciones y
combinaciones de ellas ahora lo que
veremos en este vídeo es que el
enunciado 1 es de hecho equivalente al
enunciado 2 otra forma de decirlo es que
si el enunciado 1 es verdadero
entonces el enunciado 2 también lo es y
si el enunciado tous es verdadero el
enunciado 1 también lo es
o podemos escribirlo así podemos mapear
un segmento en otro usando
transformaciones rígidas si y sólo si
los dos segmentos tienen la misma
longitud entonces cómo podemos
demostrarlo bueno lo primero que nos
gustaría demostrar es que si el
enunciado 1 es verdadero
entonces el enunciado 2 también lo es
como podemos demostrar esto como siempre
te recomiendo que pausas el vídeo y lo
intentes
bien vamos a trabajar juntos algunas
pruebas como esta pueden ser difíciles
ya que parecen ser muy intuitivas sin
embargo una forma de demostrarlo es
pensar que por definición las
transformaciones rígidas preservan
longitudes entonces por definición las
transformaciones rígidas
preservan longitudes eso es lo que las
hace rígidas entonces si un segmento
se puede mapear en otro
usando transformaciones rígidas deben
tener la misma longitud original deben
tener la misma longitud original
otra forma de decirlo es entonces el
enunciado 2 es verdadero muy bien ahora
podemos intentar demostrarlo a la
inversa veamos si podemos demostrar que
si el enunciado 2 es verdadero
entonces el enunciado 1 es verdadero
porque no pausas el vídeo y también lo
intentas
bien supongamos que el segmento ave y el
segmento [ __ ] tienen la misma longitud
por lo tanto cumplen la condición 2 para
mapear ave en sede
todo lo que tenemos que hacer son dos
transformaciones primero vamos a
trasladar el segmento ave hasta que el
punto am
este m sobre el punto ce hasta que el
punto am esté sobre el punto cm y lo
siguiente que haremos es rotar a b hasta
que el punto b esté sobre el punto de
hasta que el punto b esté sobre el punto
d y lo hemos logrado para cualesquiera
dos segmentos con la misma longitud
siempre podemos trasladar uno de ellos
hasta que tengamos un par de puntos
superpuestos y luego para que los otros
puntos se superpongan solo tenemos que
derrotarlo
ya sabemos que esto funcionará porque
tienen la misma longitud por lo tanto
acabamos de demostrar que sí podemos
mapear un segmento en otro usando
transformaciones rígidas entonces
sabemos que tienen la misma longitud y
que si dos segmentos tienen la misma
longitud entonces podemos mapear un
segmento en otro usando transformaciones
rígidas
y hemos acabado